- So, in the past two, three days,
Elon Musk has been
having a meltdown on Twitter.
First he came out against ESG
scores, which essentially determines
how environmentally conscious,
socially aware, and ethical a company is.
Elon claims that ESG ratings are a scam,
which have been weaponized
by social justice warriors.
He then claimed that,
"political attacks against him
will escalate dramatically
in the coming months."
And then he posted this.
According to Elon Musk, the real
purpose of the ESG scores,
is to determine how compliant your
business is with "the leftist agenda",
whatever that is.
Shortly after he came out
as a Republican, writing that
in the past he voted Democrat because
they were the mostly kindness party,
but they have become the party of division
and hate, so he can no longer support them.
And underneath his post
we have Lauren Boebert,
crazy Republican
far-right QAnon believer,
congratulating him
for joining the right side.
And then, woah! What's this? An article
came out on Business Insider,
claiming that Elon Musk sexually
harassed a SpaceX flight attendant.
Wow! So, was Elon Musk
actually correct about something?
Did those far-left, insane SJWs
really go on the offensive against him
after he turned towards the Republican Party?
Of course not. Elon Musk
is lying to you, as usual.
The real reason for Elon Musk's
Twitter meltdown is as follows.
On the 18th of May in the morning,
Elon Musk was sitting around, salty,
after Tesla was kicked out of
the S&P 500's ESG index.
Based on the CNBC article, this happened
due to Tesla's lack of low-carbon strategy,
and the codes of business conduct, along
with racism and poor working conditions
at Tesla's Fremont factory in California.
Then, at approximately 9 AM, people from the
Business Insider reached out to him in private,
asking him to comment on the story,
which was not yet published.
And this was the story I showed you earlier.
The one about Elon Musk sexually
harassing a SpaceX employee.
And before the article would go live,
he quickly posted this:
And then he made a post about being
a Republican, and then the article came out,
approximately one day later.
So, yeah. What's happening here is Elon Musk
trying to get out of a sexual harassment
accusation by framing it as some sort of
baseless political attack
by the insane SJW far-left.
And in that process, he gets to publicly align
himself with the political party he has always
been aligned with basically. You know,
Republicans, anti-union, anti-worker,
anti-anti-racism, and so on.
So Elon is just being the usual
piece of shit he has always been,
he's just now being more open about it.
And that's what's behind #ElonGate.